spalding is no longer going to be the
official ball of the nba is it wilson
now
ah deal get this out of here
what's up gq i'm simulu and these are my
[Music]
essentials hey when we rap
it's all fair game all right first we
got to talk about asian snacks so many
asian kids like myself when we brought
these snacks to school we used to get
made fun of right because the kids
wouldn't know what they were so now
we're here to demystify them let's start
with pockies these are sweet they're
delicious they're crunchy
just the way i remembered them
representation matters and it's about
more than just you know actors on a
screen it's about snacks it's about food
it's about culture in every possible way
japanese rice crackers they're like
wonderfully sweet savory kind of rice
cakes shredded squid
absolutely delicious don't give me that
look i know you give them that look
right now from across the screen
white rabbit candy otherwise known as da
by tulle delicious iconic lemon tea
drink from veda lunchbox staple and my
personal favorite shrimp crackers shrimp
crackers is actually exactly what i was
eating when i got the call that i was
gonna play chongqi i just woken up from
a nap it was about 6 30 in the evening i
was eating some shrimp crackers at my
desk
then i get a call from an unknown number
in burbank california and
you know my heart immediately skips a
beat because i know that disney head
office is in burbank had a feeling that
this was going to be the call and so i i
picked up the phone kevin feige's voice
in the other end telling me that i was
going to be shanxi and
basically realized that my life would be
changed forever
so this isn't your average pair of
scuffed up worn in jordans all right
these are
movie worn jordan accesses you know i'm
pretty sure there is a marvel pa out
there still trying to track these down
but guess what on my last day of
shooting i did manage to swipe them you
could tell with that you know these have
been artistically scuffed this is not
even real dirt but i believe that these
were the shoes that were worn for the
iconic bus scene i split kicked two bad
guys with these shoes so pretty sweet
mems
they're definitely gonna go in a case
displayed somewhere
until somebody i live with tells me that
i can't keep these around anymore very
shrimp crackers
so very important to travel with a solid
pair of sunglasses these are a pair of
hugo bosses it's always a struggle for
me i have a very wide face and so most
sunglasses i try on are just a bit too
skinny these i feel like frame my face
kind of nice
my favorite part is that they actually
snap off and all of a sudden you've got
a very distinguished scholarly look
but then
deal with it it seems like the more
money i spend on sunglasses
the faster i lose them there's just like
one pair of 12 sunglasses i bought at
the santa monica pier like
eight years ago and that one seems to be
the only one that never gets lost it
happens more often than i'd like to
admit i'm hoping these ones make it more
than like the six to eight month mark
this is bubble tea aka boba aka shinjuku
naicha it is the iconic drink of asian
america just like shanxi and the legend
of the ten rings will be the iconic
movie of asian america these are all 50
sweet still doesn't change the fact that
they're uh a lot you've got things that
are a little bit more milky so this is a
jasmine milk tea right here you have
things that are a little bit more fruity
this is a strawberry green tea with a
lychee jelly and you got uh some you
know new flavors as well this is a milk
foam winter melon drink i like a good
grip with the straw you know i don't
like them to be too small otherwise you
know you can suck up a bunch at once i
really like the one boba at a time kind
of situation you just got to make sure
that you cover the top and then you go
in and you go in nice and firm just one
two three pop break the seal stir it
around a little bit and go in and enjoy
that is good boba i never
was a watch collector growing up my dad
was never into watches i mean we
literally grew up so poor and came from
like absolutely nothing so i never
really knew too much about watches so i
really just went on the look and the
feel of it one of my favorite watches to
wear
are iwc's this is a portrait geezer 14
karat gold this is a top gun edition
pilots watch the black band this is a 37
77 pilots watch such an iconic look with
the metal strap i have a couple of
pieces in mind that i'd love to get my
hands on but i'm also trying not to get
ahead of myself too much i really just
want to see how this movie does and
hopefully you know get to do more and
and when i get room to breathe i'll kind
of take a look at the collection and see
what pieces it needs
this is a basketball obviously i've
always been a massive basketball fan
fancy myself a player shout out to all
of my friends back home who i hoop with
so i mean i played basketball all
throughout high school was never really
any good average maybe a solid six or
seven points a game had big nba dreams
and unfortunately at the age of 32 i
feel like they're they're dashed one of
the main things probably the critical
factor is i never ended up growing past
like 5 11 and a half but i i was like
one of the bigger kids when i was 15 or
16 so i played small forward so i was
this like tiny small forward but that
being said the nba all-star
celebrity game
still very much in the cards i was
actually flatmates with ronnie chang i
mean he lived in the same hotel as me he
was like right underneath and we would
play basketball we'd play one-on-one
like hours and hours a day every day and
look i'm just gonna be real all right i
would spot him like five points to a
game to seven and i would still beat him
like 90 of the time yeah ronnie chang
sorry buddy sorry to put you on blast
like that but uh come on
love xbox this is an xbox series x black
elite controller perfect for any sort of
call of duty halo i mean i love all of
that i love playing 2k so this is an
absolute travel must for me it looks
like the lamborghini of video game
controllers like the first halo came out
right when i was like around 14 years
old and we literally played it all the
time like me and my three friends would
play i still remember so clearly hang
them high pistols only three head shots
in a row with a pistol could kill you
and that's we we got so good at it we
just kept we just kept doing it
there gun is really important for me
whether i'm playing sports or just
sitting for really long periods of time
my wonderful publicist got me these two
for the start of our press tour i've
been pretty hooked ever since it's just
really important to keep the muscles
loose
it's really nice when you don't have
time to go to the spa even though i feel
like everybody should make time to go to
the spa you just gotta treat yourself
you know
i'm usually either you know in the midst
of writing something or editing
something or reading a bunch of scripts
and the one thing that i have with me
right now that i've been editing for the
better part of the last year is my
manuscript so i wrote a book
called
we were dreamers and we're just going
through some final edits on it right now
so the pages have markings all over them
and all of that but i carry it with me
wherever i go i read it kind of over and
over and over again and i just kind of
jot down any new thoughts that i have so
we were dreamers is going to be this
beautiful story and it tells the journey
of my family from china all the way to
canada and now to hollywood graduating
with a degree in finance and accounting
losing my job ultimately making the
decision to get started in acting and
then finally taking us all the way
through to that fateful call i'm really
excited to share it with the world so it
comes out may of 2022. i wonder who
would play me
i wish i knew any actors that looked
like me it uh it's just none come to
mind well maybe like a brad pitt or
something you gotta travel with a comfy
hoodie and this is my comfy hoodie it
was gifted to me by my stylist jean yang
who is wonderful she's an amazing badass
woman she got me my very first fear of
god hoodie
number seven shout out to gene i love
you you're the best fleeced interior all
right soft to the touch the hoodie is
also an homage to colin kaepernick
that's the you know the number seven and
the colors what he stands for is just
really just you know speaking out for
racial equality i think it's something
that you know i also consider myself a
big advocate of he advocates i think for
his community i advocate for mine and we
also you know together advocate for
allyship and solidarity between groups
as well so shout out to you colin all
right thank you everybody so much for
hanging out with me and checking out my
essentials i will see you guys next time
[Music]